I want you to remember this day and for
this reason because what took place
today is a defining moment both here in
Vietnam and back in Washington in
American politics because what we're
witnessing are two radically distinctly
different agendas that have been now
laid bare for all to see at the very
same moment as you can see a historic
summit with the President of the United
States who traveled 20 plus hours to
Vietnam for a second summit negotiating
a safer world for our kids and our
grandkids what were the Democrats in
Washington doing they purposely
scheduled and hauled in Michael Kohn day
to today of course televised the entire
day of testimony and one more day
tomorrow why just to embarrass the
president they have this psychotic hate
for today on the very day the president
is holding this historic high stakes
summit think of your kids here what what
how profound in the future this may be
for them or your grandkids the
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
no more rockets being fired all over
that part of the world
threats to here threats to Guam House
Democrats they had a more important
agenda they want to embarrass the
president while he is down in
negotiations and put on a circus a
spectacle in Washington DC so I want you
to just embrace the magnitude of this
this moment because Democrats clearly
are showing their true colors this
should be a day no red no blue no
conservative no liberal no Republican a
Democrat it's about safety and security
for all of us you know what for rocket
hits some country innocent people die
well and we could have stopped it
because we now have clear evidence
revealing exactly what they care about
and what they don't care about make no
mistake about this safety and security
of we you the people is certainly not at
the top of their list instead they would
have put off these hearings to next week
instead this insatiable hatred for the
president it now consumes all of their
actions all of their thoughts as I've
been saying every second every minute
every hour of every day of every
month and frankly every year since 2015
and Donald Trump came down that
escalator in Trump Tower and what we're
seeing in Hanoi is an American leader
fighting to make the world a better
safer place what we saw in Washington
all day just hours ago non-stop was a
Democratic Party a hyperventilating
hysterical media putting politics over
country with the political charade
designed to just embarrass and trash the
president while he represents our
country abroad I thought I thought
politics stopped at the you know borders
edge right no that's why the House
Oversight Committee called on Michael
Kohn it was just convicted of lying to
Congress to once again testify now
before Congress and it was just petty
partisan politics it was a circus Ohio
Congressman Jim Jordan I think put it so
well earlier today take a look what did
you talk to mr. Schiff about mr.
chairman here we go here we go your
first big hearing your first announced
witness Michael Cohen when everyone in
this room to think about this the first
announced witness for the hundred 16th
Congress is a guy who is going to prison
in two months for lying to Congress mr.
chairman your chairmanship will always
be identified with this hearing and we
all need to understand what this is this
is the Michael Cohen hearing presented
by Lanny Davis that's right Lanny Davis
choreographed the whole darn thing
the Clintons best friend loyalist
operative Lanny Davis put this all
together you imagine if the president
gets this accomplished Wow some people
might say he deserves a Nobel Peace
Prize more than Obama now congressman
Jordan was right on this is nothing more
than a political stunt a hit job a
circus highly orchestrated by yes the
biggest Clinton supporter on the entire
earth Lanny Davis who is apparently
representing Michael Cohen for free
along with Democratic members of
Congress and yes Michael Cohen himself
here's the evidence let's take a look
did you talk to mr. Schiff about
I spoke to mr. Schiff about topics that
were going to be raised at the upcoming
hearing whoa not just what time to show
up actually what you're gonna talk about
the gentleman time expired Wow oh now we
tell people what we're going to ask them
ahead of time so they can prepare all
their answers lying atoms ship the
biggest liar in Congress he was caught
colluding again yeah I remember the tape
of him
oh talking to somebody he thought was a
Russian giving them dirt on Donald Trump
sounds like collusion now also
Congressman Jordan got to the very heart
of why the president's former personal
attorney is now participating in this
political hit job against his former
boss a whole sad saga watch this mr.
Cohen huh how long did you uh how long
do you work in the White House I never
worked in the White House that's the
point isn't it mr. Cohen no sir yes it
is no it's not so you wanted to work in
the White House no sir and get brought
to the dance sir now I was extremely
proud to be personal attorney to the
President of the United States of
America I did not want to go to the
White House now there are multiple
sources that Michael Cohen was in fact
wanting a job and lobbying for a job at
the White House Southern District of New
York who prosecuted Cohen they stated
quote the following during and after the
campaign cone privately told friends and
colleagues including in these text
messages that he expected to be given a
prominent role and title in the new
administration and think about this that
means under oath that people cared more
about their agenda Michael Cohen is
already going to jail and they put him
at further risk for further charges down
the road now that was not the only
inconsistency he also said that the
president didn't want to win the
election at all but then later said that
Trump wanted to win at all costs and
even hinting at collusion but without
any evidence he accused the president of
campaign finance violations as it
relates to stormy Daniels also said that
the payment was intended to protect his
brand because running for president was
just one big marketing campaign it's a
marketing campaign the only collusion
might have been
Oh Trump Tower Moscow which everybody
knew about and so much more take a look
we know mr. Cohen has been dishonest in
the past that's why he's going to prison
in two months but there are things today
that he said during the several hours of
questioning that just don't add up
either he said he never defrauded any
bank he was having a conversation
questioning from mr. comer obviously
that's not true because he's going to
prison for that very offense your first
big hearing the first announced witness
of the hundred sixteenth Congress is a
gentleman who is going to prison in two
months for lying to Congress I don't
think that's what we should be focused
on all the way Fox News just got word
that there might be a walk-in just mere
minutes with the president and Kim Jeong
RunAs that summit is now underway here
in Hanoi in Vietnam now here's the
problem
Democrats don't care one bit about
Michael Cohen and his family not at all
because they were the ones calling him
every name in the book until fairly
recently now as a result of their
partisan hatred of Trump they don't care
about Michael Cohen they don't care
about his family and they may have put
him in further legal jeopardy with the
Southern District of New York that
seemed pretty mad at him already on
issues involving inconsistencies for
nearly seven hours under oath at the
request of House Democrats Michael Kohn
was frankly used by Democrats on this
historic day to advance what is now a
psychotic hate Trump mob that exists in
this country yet during all the
testimony we saw no evidence Oh Trump
Russia collusion we saw no evidence of
any crimes committed by the president
nothing in fact Michael Cohen himself
actually shot down some of the hate
Trump media mobs favorite conspiracies
I'm sure this is hurting them a little
watch this the questions have been
raised about whether I know of direct
evidence that mr. Trump or his campaign
colluded with Russia I do not if you
have been to Prague I've never been to
Prague never I have I've never been to
the Czech Republic are you aware of
anything that the president
has done at home or abroad that may have
subjected him to or may subject him to
extortion or blackmail I am not know
okay are you aware of any videotapes
that may be the subject of extortion or
blackmail I've heard about these tapes
for a long time I've had many people
contact me over the years I have no
reason to believe that that tape exists
so you had a conversation with the
president United States about your
impending testimony before the House
Intelligence Committee is that correct
that's correct what was the nature of
that conversation he wanted me to
cooperate they have it the media's
Russian collusion hysteria two long
years total BS by their new BFF nothing
more than a conspiracy theory and just
like we've been telling you but there is
real Russia collusion as we've
chronicled we won't go into that tonight
without a doubt Michael Cohen has been
through a lot
his family has been through a lot and
Michael Cohen pled guilty to multiple
felonies he's lost his law license he's
now facing three years in prison there
is absolutely nothing for him to gain
from today's political theater and the
question is why would Democrats they
didn't have a political agenda open up
Michael Kohn and his family to even
greater risk
you saw all of that play out today in
real time look at the house freedom
caucus chairman mark meadows issuing a
criminal referral over cones testimony
today great job Democrats you really
helped out your friend take a look did
you have foreign contracts over the last
two years foreign contracts contracts
with foreign entities did you have your
address yes yes why didn't you put them
on the forum nothing to do with lobbying
it says it's a criminal offence to not
list all your foreign contracts that's
what it says well then I'm gonna take a
look at it before I leave you know it's
just one more example mr. Cohen of your
skirting the truth now congressman
meadows will be with us later in the
show but look at what the Democrats
because they still want to smear
President Trump I think they cared about
Michael
his family now he's facing more legal
issues more trouble for his life and his
family and that's no concern to the
radical far left Democratic Party the
ones that are so compassionate wiliness
smear slammed it for smerch around
anybody any place any time
it's why radical socialist congresswoman
watched elite remember actually implying
that congressman mark Meadows was a
racist for bringing an African American
former Trump Organization employee to
the hearing to vouch for the president
an incredible exchange also showed a lot
about the chairman of this committee
right now Elijah Cummings take a look at
this the fact that someone would
actually use a prop a black woman in
this chamber in this committee is a lone
racist in itself mr. chairman there's
nothing more personal to me than my
relationship my nieces and nephews are
people of color not many people know
that you know that miss mr. chairman and
to indicate that I asked someone who is
a personal friend of the the Trump
family who is work for him who knows
this particular individual that she's
coming in to be a prop it's racist to
suggest that I asked her to come in here
for that reason tomatoes you know and of
all the people on this committee I've
said it and got in trouble for it that
you one of my best friends I know that
shocks a lot of people and likewise me
but you are and I would do and I could
see and feel your pain and and to my
colleague mr. meadows that was not my
intention and I do apologize if that's
what it sounded like but I said someone
in general yeah she was talking about
Marc meadows and wouldn't admit it by
the way what incredible I don't agree
with congressman Elijah Cummings
incredible grace class what a moment for
him and Marc meadows ow is that by the
way the same congresswoman that called
the president mother bleep door in the
the same personal pals around with Linda
Sarsour a virulent anti-semite and
actually wrote a column for Louis
Farrakhan's newspaper she represents all
that is wrong with today's modern
extreme radical Democratic Socialist
Party it's their actions their conduct
their beliefs couldn't be any more
disgraceful that's a party consumed by
hate radical ideas they can't even put
politics aside at the water's edge for
one week and support this vitally
important mission of the President
abroad party now embracing socialism
over capitalism a party supporting an
insane green New Deal over real life
prosperity of the American people a
party voting against the bill that would
protect babies born alive that survived
an abortion a party that wants to
abolish ice even knock down the wall
that protects us we still get 90% of
heroin in this country they want
unfettered illegal immigration open
borders a party that trashed your right
to due process unless it impacts a
member of their own party in other words
Cavanaugh versus the lieutenant governor
of Virginia a party that doesn't value
the rule of law Constitution our way of
life that has created wealth happiness
prosperity for more people than any
other governmental system in the history
of mankind and we have shared it with
the world a Democratic Party this was a
national disgrace today what we saw in
Washington